tout ça parce que j'ai eu deux enfants sur la
banquette arrière qui ne me ressemblent pas
cette dame a pris sur elle de
dire qu'elle va descendre mon assiette
et appeler la police je ne peux pas sortir avec
deux enfants qui ne me ressemblent pas  moi et
sans que quelque chose soit bizarre regarde la
police est là maintenant la police
m bébé j'ai deux enfants je fais du
babysitting nous avons mangé un métro à Walmart
quand tu as des gars elle s'est arrêtée en
parlant d'autres enfants
ok pourquoi ça ne irait pas personne ne crie
personne n'a crié quand il essayait de
s'enfuir  elle est partie est revenue et a dit demander
à voir la petite fille pour qu'elle puisse lui
demander si elle est là elle sait qui je suis
ouais d'accord et puis je suis allé
chercher de l'essence chez Murphy elle est revenue
là-bas c'est fou
je veux dire pourquoi c'était  pour se sentir entendu, ils ont
obtenu une faute s'il vous plaît expliquer à l'officier
qui mr.  Lewis est s'il
vous plaît pour vous 34 équipes ensemble d'accord
alors comme là
non elle était juste je suppose que je suis venu
mais deux enfants blancs étant avec un
homme noir non oui je travaille avec des enfants tous les jours
il a un 20-18 je peux sortir pour  la
communauté sans être profil